We Begin the program in Russia where the
State security service the FSB has
reportedly dropped criminal cases in
relation to the Wagner group's armed
Mutiny on Saturday it's part of an offer
made by President Vladimir Putin to end
the Rebellion it also includes an offer
for Exile in Belarus flight radar shows
a jet link to the Wagner group has
landed in Belarus from Russia there's
speculation on whether or not the
founder yevgeny pregosian was on board
but a Russian President Alexander
lukashenko brokered the deal with
progosian in his latest comments Luka
Shanker said he put his country's Army
at the ready during the Mutiny Russia's
defense Ministry says Wagner group
Fighters are preparing to hand over
equipment Putin stressed his offer in an
address to the nation on Monday evening
let's bring in Yulia chapovalova who's
in Moscow for us Julia plenty of moving
parts to this story break it all down
for us firstly let's start with the
latest from the FSB who has dropped or
which has dropped the charges why is
that significant explain it to us
yes of course it's official the case of
the Armed Rebellion is closed on June
the 27th that's according to the FSB uh
they also stated that when investigating
the case of the Rebellion it was
established that its participants had
stopped actions directly aimed at at
committing a crime and now preparations
are underway for a transfer of Wagner
group's heavy military equipment to
units of the Russian armed forces and
that's according to the defense Ministry
statement so Putin has kept his word to
drop charges against preggers and his
Wagner group they won't be prosecuted
yesterday on Monday there was a lot of
noise really about the information that
the criminal charges against pregosian
were not dropped but many here never
questioned Vladimir Putin's Authority
they were saying that simply a little
bit of patience was needed because the
procedure itself had to take some time
and couldn't be carried out during days
off and Monday was a day off in Moscow
yesterday by the way many opposition
journalists some of them are in Exile
now they are outraged by the decision to
drop all the charges against pregosian
and let him and his people go they say
while ordinary Russians receive huge
fines and prison terms for just calling
the special military operation in
Ukraine a war for criticizing the Army
and the authorities people like Ferguson
walk free after an armed Rebellion which
could have led to a massive unrest in
the country
yes speaking of progression we said
earlier before Crossing to you that he
has actually fled Russia or there are
conflicting reports on where he is let's
take a look at the flight path that we
think that he may have taken it's
believed that pragosian has gone from
rostov in Russia and has flown to an air
base in Belarus what are you hearing
Julia about whether or not he was on
board this particular flight
well basically pretty much the same
thing progression is an exile and their
eyes you said conflicting reports about
his whereabouts allegedly his Business
Jet was supported on its way to Belarus
but some Russian sources here also say
that his jet is probably in Saint
Petersburg where the Wagner headquarters
are pregosian uh has been declared a
traitor here his Wagner mercenary group
uh was nearly disbanded and disarmed
some would probably sign contracts with
the ministry of defense and others will
probably go to Belarus so experts allege
that pregocion will probably keep the
most Comet ready units for himself about
10 or 15 000 people to fulfill duties
outside Russia not here but uh well also
we can't immediately verify those
reports
um well also according to newspaper
Telegraph Russian intelligence Services
threatens to harm the families of the
organelle leaders during the Mutiny that
was reported by UK security sources
certainly plenty of moving Parts Yulia
and another element to this developing
story is the Bella Russian president's
role in all of this he's spoken this
morning local time what's he had to say
um so Mr lukashenko said that the threat
of a new global conflict has never been
so close and he blamed NATO for igniting
conflicts and he also added that if
Russia collapses they will remain well
there I mean Belarus and Alexander
lukashenka will remain under the rubble
and all of them will die that's
according to Alexander lukashenko and uh
he obviously said that he gave all
orders to bring the Army to full combat
Readiness during the Mutiny in Russia so
there is an opinion that lukashenko has
strengthened his power due to the Wagner
Rebellion here now he has nuclear
weapons and the Wagner group there both
were given to him by Vladimir Putin and
while people in Belarus are outraged as
they fear for their safety and their
life because of the Wagner presence in
their country and for strengthening of
the lukashenko regime so in a nutshell
people admit Putin's and pregosian's
reputation has been uh
can celebrate a little victory
plenty happening there thanks so much
for breaking it all down for us Yulia
shapovalova in Moscow